INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
So in or up to this
point at least,
we've gotten through a lot of
the kind of data setup steps.
We got through the process of
how to collect data or one way
to collect data, the fact
that we need to collect data.
We also talked about
how to label data.
And now we're going to close out
this loop on train or machine
learning by showing how we can
train and thereby also deploy
models to be used in practice.
Because up to now,
again, all we have
is a bunch of images
or text or whatever
it is that has information,
has known labels.
But really, the thing that
makes machine learning machine
learning is that we can find
the patterns in this data set
and then use those to make
predictions on new data and data
that we haven't seen before.
And so to that end, we're
going to walk through today
a tool called SageMaker Canvas.
Now, this is not by
any means the only
or I would even argue the most
common way to train models.
I'll show some more things,
probably in another video,
I don't think we'll have enough
time in this video, of ways
that it's done more commonly,
but this is probably
the easiest way if you don't
have any experience coding.
I know we've done a lot of or at
least showing you a lot of code
up to this point,
but I'm not expecting
you guys to have seen or
have done any coding yet.
And so if you're
not at that point,
or maybe if you're
working in an organization
or want to empower
some users that
aren't as confident from
a coding side of things,
a tool like SageMaker Canvas
is a really good option.
Now, that being said
too, SageMaker Canvas
is by no means the go to
or the only solution as far
as point and click or
no code/low code machine
learning tools go.
There's tools like
RapidMiner that
are ones that you
might download locally.
There are other tools that
you can leverage, other AutoML
tools in the cloud for this.
So there's a lot of
options out there.
We're just going to
show one and give you
the idea of how
it works roughly.
So to do that, the first
thing we need to do
is actually download
or set up our working--
our environment for it.
So the AWS account really
by default doesn't have
or doesn't have a
SageMaker Studio domain.
And again, this is getting
really specific into SageMaker
specific tools, so I'm
not going to harp on this
too much because it's
not critical that exactly
how SageMaker sets this up.
So we'll walk through
these steps or breeze
through these steps
a little quickly,
but I'll try to give you a high
level idea of what it's doing.
I put some notes
on Canvas for this,
but you can also just
go to the website link
that I provided in those notes.
This is just the tutorial we're
going to walk through here.
It's a good walkthrough of
what this tool affords us.
But to do this, we're going to
start by just clicking this AWS
CloudFormation stack link.
So if you do this, it'll
take you to this environment
right here, this page right
here that creates or is--
basically walks through this
YAML file, this setup file,
this template to create a
bunch of things for us, right.
So you see here
it's free an account
without a pre-existing SageMaker
Studio domain, and a SageMaker
user profile, and so
that'll be anybody
who hasn't done this yet.
So this will be
necessary, because you
should be running this again
on your personal account.
This template also includes
the additional permissions
which are required
to run this tutorial.
And so you'll see as we go
through or as it gets deployed,
it's going to be creating roles
and all kinds of other things.
So it's effectively
like saying, hey,
rather than us doing every
one of the steps that's
necessary for this and
me walking through each
of these individual
steps of creating roles
and setting up user
accounts and user profiles,
it's the same for anybody
that wanted to do it.
So we can just run through
this kind of CloudFormation,
stack that, I'll
spin everything up.
So you don't need
to change anything.
If you click this link,
it'll pre-populate
all this information for you.
All you need to say is
that I acknowledge-- oh,
and I guess I could shrink
myself out of the way.
I'm really bad about remembering
to shrink myself out of the way,
but in here, I'll slide
myself down to the bottom.
But either way, you won't need
to change anything on this page.
It'll be preconfigured with
all the information necessary.
You just need to
acknowledge that it's--
you're allowing it to do this.
So we'll click Create, and then
this will take a good minute.
This will probably take
around 10 minutes-ish.
So you're more welcome to pause
and come back to it from here.
But I will say a few things
more while this is running.
So here, let me drag this
out of the way for a second.
So a couple of things
I want to highlight
is that this is by no
means the cheapest way
to train machine
learning models.
And this is why, again,
I am not expecting you,
if you are not comfortable
with it, again,
having any sort of potential
cost running in your account,
you don't need to
run this one locally.
We're not going to test on
it or anything like that
or expect you to execute on it.
I just want you to
see these tools.
But if you want to
follow along, I'll
at least give you a rough idea
of what pricing looks like.
So you can see here that first
off, for using SageMaker canvas,
they pay based off of
the number of hours
that Canvas is used
or logged into.
So the second we launch
it and connect to it,
it's going to start charging
us a $1.90 per hour.
It's a nontrivial amount.
Again, in a single
day, that'll be over--
what, almost 40 bucks, almost
50 bucks of cost there?
That's pretty substantial,
just to be on this platform.
Aside from that-- and
there is a free tier,
so I'll give you that.
But either way, that's
the starting cost.
Then from there, it also
charges you based off
of the size of your data set.
Now, there is some
necessity to that
because the larger a
data set is, arguably,
the more processing
time it will require.
But it's not that cut and dry.
It's not that Black and white.
Also, the prices
are a little steep.
So you can see
here, they basically
charge per cell, which
they define as cell,
as just how many--
if you think about an Excel
spreadsheet for a second,
you have rows and
you have columns.
The cells are each of
those values that intersect
with a row and column.
So basically, if you
multiply the number of rows
by the number of columns,
that will give you
the number of cells.
So if you had 100
columns and 10,000 rows,
that would be a million cells.
And you can see
here that they're
going to basically charge, for
the first 10 million cells,
$30 per million cells.
So for example, again, with this
100 column 10,000 row data set,
that would already be
$30 to train this model.
That's pretty substantial.
So here, for example, when
running a modeling job
with a data set of
25.5 million cells,
the training charge to be
based on $30 per million
times the first 10 million
cells, and $15 per million
for the next 16 million cells.
And that would come
out to a total of $540.
And I scratch my head because
it's a really high price.
I don't know necessarily where
they came up with these numbers
from.
It's not uncommon to
use a data set that
far exceeds a million cells.
Let me see if I can
pull up one of the data
sets that I use in
a different class.
And one of my or in my
regression and machine learning
class here-- let me
sort this by the size.
Let's do the list.
So I'll just show you what I'm
looking at as I'm doing this,
and I'll pull up the
largest file I have here.
So let's pull up this one and
see how many rows and columns
it is.
So we have 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11 columns and 10,000 rows, OK?
This one's not terrible.
Or did I sort--
I sorted the wrong
direction, didn't I?
Let's see.
Oh, this might actually
be the largest one
I work with in this class.
Oh, it's because the
large ones are in folder.
Sorry.
That's why.
So let's actually come here.
I think it is--
this one might be larger.
Yes, this is 48 megabytes here.
So let's look at this one.
There we go.
So I think there's something
like 100 or so columns.
It's the human activity
recognition data set.
Maybe I might be able
to pull up the link.
Activity recognition.
So this is the data set here,
and this is me going off
track for a second.
Yeah, I believe it's this one.
Got this link here.
So yeah, 120 instances.
No, there's definitely
much more than that.
I think it's because it
hasn't been rotated out.
But here, let's
just come to this.
This machine learning repository
is a good source for data sets
and some pretty
common data sets.
So if I were just to sort
by the number of instances,
the number of observations,
you can see here,
I have used most of these
large data sets here,
but let's take something
like this bag of words.
That is, 800 or 8 million
rows by 100,000 columns.
And again, not an unreasonable
size of a data set to work with.
And that would be, let's
see, divided by 100,000.
All right.
So that's that.
Let's divide by 1 million.
So yeah, that would be
800,000 something dollars.
I can't even do the math here.
Either way, it's an unholy cost
for the amount of stuff here.
So this is why I am joking
or hand-waving around.
You need to be
mindful of the cost
if you're using
a tool like this.
But again, they
can be very useful
if you're working with
somebody that doesn't really
know what they're doing or
doesn't really have the capacity
to train a model in a simpler
way or better statement,
just needs a point
and click scenario.
There is a free tier though.
So the free tier
provides two months,
includes up to 750 hours
per month, and up to 10
model creation
requests per month.
So if you can keep your
size under a million cells
and you only do 10
models per month
and you don't use the sessions
for over 750 hours per month,
then it's free.
So it's decent-ish
in the free tier,
but it gets a little
pricey after that.
Either way, I'm
going to pause now
because it's going to take a
while for this to get launched.
So I'll come back
here in a second.
Now, once that
process is complete,
you can come back over here
or go back to your console,
open up SageMaker,
and you should
be able to click this Canvas
tab on the left hand side,
and you should see a
studio user here now.
That studio user,
again, is the one
that's created by this
whole CloudFormation stack.
If you haven't been
able to get it to work
or if it threw some error,
a shortcut or a workaround
that I've been
able to use before
is to just use a different
region because you can only
have one domain per region.
But if you just switch
to a different region
than you already have, it
won't have anything there.
So for example, if I
click US East Ohio--
I don't think I've
used this one.
Exactly.
So you can-- if I wanted to
create an account here or be
able to connect in Ohio, I
could just come to this one--
let me try to increase my
size again one more time,
and then click Launch
SageMaker Canvas,
and just walk through
his quick setup steps.
It's literally just
select quick step
and select Launch or
submit, and that would also
allow you to create this.
But because I already or I have
it working now in my US West 2
location, yours, if you
click through the link,
will be in US East 1.
I can come over
here to Canvas now,
and I have my
studio user located.
And so you can just
click Open Canvas.
I've already launched this
because it takes, again,
probably about five-ish
minutes to set up
the first time you run it.
So to save time, I've
already done that,
but you'll need to do that
there as well for yours.
So this is what it
will look like once
you're able to finally
get it launched.
You might have these same
prepackaged sample data
sets that got loaded with it.
That's perfectly OK.
What we're going to
do though first is,
we're going to import some data.
So if I come over here to S3--
this is all [INAUDIBLE] at
S3, I've uploaded two files.
And I'll put these on Canvas as
well, though they're also listed
in the notes for this tutorial.
But I've put two files in here.
One is called
shipping logs, and one
is called product descriptions.
These are both CSV files.
I've uploaded them
to this bucket.
You can upload
them to any bucket.
It shouldn't matter which
one you upload them to.
But once you do that--
and again, those
will be on Canvas
or just click on the links in
the tutorial or the walkthrough.
I'll drag it up here
on the screen again
so you can see it, OK?
Scroll down here.
If you click these
two links, it'll
just open up a browser window
and download each of them,
and then you can upload
them to your Canvas
or to your S3 bucket.
But coming back to Canvas now,
I'm going to go Import, S3.
So I'm going to import this data
from S3, the data 3,600 demo,
and then these two data
sets are right there,
shipping logs and
product descriptions.
So I'll click Import
Data, and you'll
see they're getting
imported now.
We'll wait a few seconds.
You'll also see that it
specifies the number of columns
and the number of rows.
And then if you multiply
those two values together,
it gives you the
number of cells.
And remember, they charge
per million cells, $30.
So again, a little steep
pricing, but for now,
we're well under
the free tier limit.
Once I've done that, I want
to create a new data set here.
So what I did, I'll
just highlight again,
I'm going to join
these two data sets,
shipping logs and
product descriptions,
the same way I'd run
a join if I'd use SQL,
and I'm just going to
drag and drop those
both onto this screen.
And you'll notice, it's
automatically created a link.
And it's correct,
what we have here.
We have an inner
join, and we want
them both to be
joined on there or we
want them to be joined
on their product ID.
This is a shared product ID.
So this is a way you
can do this join stuff.
Now this is assuming a
relatively clean data set.
This works well
because we've already
or we know this is
cleaned in advance,
but this wouldn't necessarily
work with all data sets.
And so you can see
then, we do that.
It even has some things like
distinct values, mean and mode,
missing values here.
We won't worry
about that just yet,
and we'll just
import these first.
And so I'm going
to call this one--
I forget what I called it here.
Yeah, consolidated
shipping data.
And we'll click Import Data.
And this data set--
let's see here,
have a note on it.
Yeah, it's trying to-- so
what we're trying to do
is we're trying to predict
the estimated time of arrival
of shipments in days.
And the data set
contains shipping data
for delivered
products, estimated
time shipping priority,
carrier, the origin.
So a bunch of features.
We can actually click on
this data set, I believe,
and yeah, preview it here.
So you can see we have actual
shipping days, expected shipping
days, who the carrier is, the
shipping distance, x and y,
and both the x and y
dimensions, bulk order
versus single order, the origin,
the date and ID, shipping
priority, on time delivery,
brand, the model, screen size,
and then the package weight.
So all these features
we have about it
and we're trying to say,
OK, given this information,
can I predict how long it
actually will take to ship?
And if you see in
there, we actually
had that label, that actual
shipping days, that's our label.
This is us having already gone
through the labeling process.
We saw what the true label
was or the true outcome
was for some
historical packages.
And so now we can
use this, say, well,
what are the patterns
in here that tell us
that maybe some
shipping location,
or whether it's a
priority status,
or the size of the screen?
Does any of that
tell me something
about the kind of task at
hand or a better statement,
the time it takes to
get the product shipped?
So once I have that
created, then I'm
going to click on Models.
And I've already
created a model.
You won't have one
here, but I'm just
going to click New
Model for a second,
and let's call this
one shipping forecast.
We'll click Create.
And the first thing
or you can see here,
it breaks it down to four steps.
We have a select step, build
step, analyze, and predict.
First step is just
select our data set.
And so we're going to take our
consolidated shipping data set,
click Select Data
Set, and then now it's
going to ask us to first
select the column that we
want to predict.
So this is our target.
And we're trying to predict
the actual shipping days.
And you can see
here a distribution
of the actual number
of shipping days.
There's one that took zero
days, maybe that's some noise.
Again, this is the reality of
not being able to clean it.
Is we don't really know
exactly why that's in there,
but we'll look here, and you
can see that the average is
somewhere in this region.
It probably will tell us
somewhere on this screen
with the averages.
But either way, we're hovering
somewhere in the middle here
for the average
around two weeks-ish.
And then on the high
end, some things
are taking almost four weeks.
So we want to go with
actual shipping days.
And then you see
here, try to infer
or basically assume that it
was a time series forecasting
problem, and that's
mostly because there was
a date column in this data set.
Because it included
date, it was like, well,
maybe this is actually
a time series problem
and I should be considering it.
And notice that it actually
grays it out when you do it,
because I can't remove it here.
But this isn't actually
a time series problem.
We're just saying
generically, we
want to know the number of
days it will take to ship.
And so it's a numeric
prediction problem.
I'm predicting a number.
You can see your estimate,
the value of your column.
An example business
case is how long
it is it will take for a
package to be delivered.
Versus a time series forecasting
and say, how will my sales
be affected if I
raise the prices,
or how much inventory should I
order for the holiday season?
In that sense, I'm
considering this time effect
that's happening.
We don't really
have the capability
of doing a two category
model because we
have more than two categories
in our response variable
and our target variable.
But if we had two outcomes,
a yes/no answer, then that
would be the one we select.
And if we had more
than one outcome,
then we could do
something like this.
Now, granted, again,
more than one outcome
means it's still
categorical in this sense.
So will it deliver be
early, on time, or late?
There's three options here, so
it's a categorical prediction.
But there's not a continuous
set of predictions,
so we can't use that one or
we shouldn't use that one.
So we'll do numeric
prediction there.
And again, now we can see
we have columns and a bunch
of information about them.
We also even have things like
the correlation to target.
So how strong is the correlation
between the target variable
and each of these
specific columns?
Now, I'll note that I'm pretty
sure this is doing-- yeah,
this is doing
linear correlation.
So we could say that there is
no relationship between these
and drop these, and that's
what they do in the tutorial.
As a statistician,
I'll say that this
is a little bit of a fuzzy thing
to do here because again, we
don't know for sure that there
isn't some sort of nonlinear
relationship.
This is not a statistics
class, so I won't
worry about all these issues.
I'm trying to just turn off my
statistics brain for a second.
So we'll just do what
they say for now,
and we'll drop off the
shipping distance in the x
and y direction.
And then also, I'm going to drop
off the product ID and order ID,
because that really doesn't
have anything to predict.
That shouldn't contain
any information since--
for example here,
there's a unique order ID
for every single different--
for every different
order that happened.
And so there's going to be a
new order ID for a new example.
So I couldn't even train
a model or I couldn't even
make a prediction
on a new observation
because I wouldn't have
seen that order ID before.
So it just makes more
sense to drop that off.
And similarly, with
the product ID,
I could conceivably
include that,
but I might not
want it to overfit
necessarily to something
specific about the product
itself.
It's the primary key or one of
the keys we use in this joining,
so I'm just going to
drop that one out.
Note, you can also see if
there's any mismatch columns.
So if it seems to be a different
type than the type specified
for the column or if
there's any missing data,
this doesn't have any issues.
So we can go ahead and happily
move on, but that's there.
If you click this little
grid view thing too,
you can also see distributions,
like screen size distribution,
package weight distribution.
This can also be helpful if
you're looking for weird cases.
If, for example,
in the screen size,
we saw only one observation way
out here, like 100 something,
well, then we know
that it's probably
just an error in
the data collection
and we should drop
that observation.
But from first glance,
this looks good.
So now we can get on
to the analyze step,
and that's done by
fitting a model,
by building the model
in their verbiage.
And you have two
options to go with.
You have standard build
and you have quick build.
Standard build, you can see
takes between two to four hours.
The reason this takes so
long is because there's
a lot of different
machine learning
models we could choose from.
And since we're trying to
let the computer, the Amazons
models, automatically
determine the correct model
to fit to this data,
you have this outcome
or this effect where
they have to try
so many different combinations.
And if I say I'm willing
to wait two to four hours,
then they're going to try
every single combination
to see if they can get that last
little bit of performance out.
Now, the actual
change in performance
might be so minuscule
between the first model
they try and the model
after four hours,
and so we might actually not get
a huge magnitude in improvement.
But it might show
some improvement,
and therefore, they'll
take that as a win.
I would argue as again, from a
statistician's point of view,
it's not very appropriate
to worry about that.
We should take a much
more principled approach
and try things that
make sense for our data.
But again, not a
statistics class.
We're just treating this as a
magic black box for a second.
And so we can go this route and
choose either standard build
or quick build,
which says, OK, let's
not fit as many
different combinations.
Let's just try a few models.
Takes 2 to 15 minutes.
I would argue again, for
a data set of this size,
it should be taking on
the order of milliseconds.
We'll ignore that for now.
We'll take quick build, and then
you can just click Quick Build.
Now, I've already run this,
but I'll click it there.
And you can see it-- when
it comes up with this,
you can just click
Start Quick Build,
and then it'll start training.
And again, it'll take
between 2 to 15 minutes.
There's some variability in it.
But I've already
trained one now,
so you can click
that, lectures run.
But now I'll go on to what
my trained model already
looks like.
So let's go back for a
second to models now.
And if I click
this one here, this
is the one I randomly
created, same data set,
you can see that once
it was fully trained,
it was able to predict the
actual number of shipping days
within a range plus
or minus of 1.22 days.
Now, that's not terrible.
If we see here, the range
of days of deliveries
were somewhere between--
forget what exactly what it was.
I think on the low end was 0 and
the high end was 28 or 26 days.
So being off by about a
day or so is pretty good.
Now, the first thing
we see here on the top
is a feature importance,
a variable importance.
So this tells us
which variables were
most important in the prediction
of the actual number of shipping
days.
Now, the first one is
the expected number
of shipping days.
Now, not knowing much
about the data set,
I'd argue that this is probably
not something I would have
included in training the
model, because that's maybe
using some other machine
learning maybe to predict,
expect how many number
of days it takes.
And so once we a good
or if we have a model
that creates a good number
of expected shipping days
and we know that,
well, then it's
not surprising that the actual
shipping days relies mostly
on that.
So arguably a more interesting
model would be to exclude that.
So maybe we'll go back
here and while this
is-- while we're
looking at this one,
we'll train a different
model where we drop off
the expected shipping days.
So let's do this, and I'll just
do Start Quick Build while we
look at our other model.
But either way,
going back to this,
we'll see now that we have on
time deliveries, the next most
important, and you can see
the relationship as far
as if it's status
is late, how far off
or how does that affect it?
On time, how does
that affect it?
Again, this is another
thing that maybe I
should exclude from the model
because this is something
I would have to
know on the outcome
or it'd have to occur
before I can know
what the expected shipping days
or the predicted shipping days
are.
So I arguably should
drop this one as well.
So it's really coming
down to shipping priority
in some of these later things.
So yeah.
Either way, irrelevant for this.
We're just trying to
see how this tool works.
And you can see now the impact
on the prediction associated
with these different categories.
Cool stuff.
Fun plots.
We're good to go.
If we click on Scoring,
you can see here this plot
shows my predicted value
for actual shipping
days versus the actual value
for actual shipping days.
And a good prediction should
result in a really tight line
here, a really tight
fit between these.
A perfect prediction
would be every dot
falls perfectly on the line.
But for the most
part here, we're
decently close to this line.
There's a pretty
strong relationship,
so I feel pretty
good about that.
If I click on that
advanced metrics as well,
you can see also the
distribution of errors,
and we do see that they're
kind of nice, symmetrical.
So for the most part, the
range of typical error
is falling between
0.71 and negative 0.71.
So again, a decent result.
Root mean squared error
of 1.22, as we saw before.
And if you're familiar with R
squared, you're getting 87.5.
That's basically
saying, the percentage
of variance explained by
this model is about 87.5%.
Again, not a statistic class.
I don't expect you to
have-- to understand
exactly why that worked.
But once we have
that, conceivably now,
we could predict
this onto new data.
We don't really have
any new data sets,
so we'll just make a prediction
onto our existing data.
But we'll see how
to do that here.
So we're doing a
Batch Prediction.
We'll click our
consolidated shipping
data, Generate Predictions.
And then it'll take
a few seconds here,
but then this will make
predictions for each
of our 10,000 observations.
But again, the important
thing here would be to do--
assuming we have a
different set, a test set,
if you want to say, that would
allow us to make our predictions
onto a new data set.
And if we preview these,
this is our predicted number
of shipping days and the
actual number of shipping days.
Predicted, actual.
So again, you can see
really good results here.
But again, arguably we leaked a
little bit too much information
in here for this.
Either way though, that is the
process of training this model.
Once we've done that, we can
go back here-- and actually,
let's see if our model
finished our other one.
Yeah.
So this other one
finished training.
You can see that the
performance was worse.
Now we're back down to 1.55.
And I'd argue, if you drop
shipping priority and arguably
on time delivery, you'd
get even worse results.
Though the worse here is just
in this numeric value because
in practice, we
could use a model
that didn't include
on time delivery--
actually, shipping
priority, we could include.
But yeah, model
that didn't include
on time delivery
or arguably date,
while it would have
worse performance,
it would actually be usable
in practice on a new data
set that we haven't seen before.
So that would be a good outcome.
But either way, yeah, once
you're done with this,
you can just come in here and
delete these models really
easily.
Just click on the little
radio buttons, Delete.
Delete.
We'll come back here
now to SageMaker.
If you've created the
CloudFormation stack,
you can also follow the
instructions on the notes there.
You could just go back to
the CloudFormation stack page
and click whichever your
relevant CloudFormation stack is
and click Delete.
Or if you've created
the other way,
I believe we should be able to
just delete our Canvas here.
So let's click here
and go Control panel.
And then I'm going to--
I haven't done this
before from this way,
so I'm just trying to see
if we can delete the domain.
Yeah, here we go.
Yeah.
So let's first go and
delete our user profiles
and then see if we
can go from there.
So the studio user,
let's go to edit maybe.
So that allow us to
delete it from here.
User cannot contain
any non failed apps.
OK.
Let me see here.
Let me actually pause
this really quick
so I don't just stall
here for a second,
but this is me trying
to do things live.
But yeah, I'll
pause and come back.
OK.
I think I got it.
So you click-- let me click
the user for a second here.
Let me delete their app first.
So this will delete
the Canvas app.
And once the app
has been deleted,
you see we can delete the user.
This other user didn't
ever have an application,
so I'm just going to
delete this one directly.
So I'll click Edit, and
then click Delete User.
Yes, delete user.
Delete that one.
And then once this one
is-- yep, that's deleted,
so we should be able to
delete this one now too.
Click Delete User.
Yes, delete user.
Delete.
And now, conceivably,
they'll allow
us to delete the domain too.
And there we go.
So let's delete my domain.
And now we won't be
incurring any new costs.
We should be good to go.
If you came back and
want to do this again,
you'd have to
start from scratch.
So either way, that's
the walk through.
That's the process for training
a machine learning model
using Canvas, using one of these
click and drag and drop tools.
In the next video,
I'll show you how
to do this and the way
I more commonly do this
by using just a coding interface
and training the model that way.
It allows us a lot
more flexibility,
is much more robust,
much easier to share.
So we'll come back to that
and show you it that way.
But I think this is
sufficient for now
so we don't run for too long.
Perfect.
Thank you very much.
And I'll see you next time.
Bye